prenez la parole depuis leur université
d'été à marseille on le regarde d'abord
je voudrais vous dire à quel point je
suis heureuse de vous retrouver et puis
dire que la blague de pascal n'est pas
tant que ça une blague parce qu il y a
dix ans exactement parce qu'il fallait
faire la parité à la tribune j'avais été
réquisitionnés pour juste être assise et
passer le micro et j'en garde un grand
souvenir parce que dany cohn-bendit
était déjà avec nous à cette époque et
que comme me l'a dit andré reversât au
travers de qui je remercie aussi tous
les militants marseillais et de la
région qui se sont engagés on n'avait
absolument pas d'argent on louait les
badges vous rendez pas compte du progrès
et puis andré m'a dit tout à l'heure
et bien si on m'avait dit que dix ans un
prêt étudiant ministre j'aurais
sacrément rigoler donc je remercie andré
je remercie pascal et je vous remercie
vous de cette histoire et du fait que je
suis ici devant vous pour vous dire si
lent qui s'annonce
celui qu'on peut appeler 2 01 ou 2014 va
être celui ce que je crois profondément
nécessaire d'un moment
d'approfondissement de courage politique
et d'engagement résolument comme l'a dit
philippe martin de la transition
parce que nous sommes ensemble ici on
est plutôt bien
je suis vraiment très heureuse de
participer à cette plénière très
heureuse de ce que j'ai entendu très
heureuse de tous les gens qui sont là
ici et vous imaginez que j'aurai encore
bien d'autres trucs à raconter dans mes
mémoires du coup mais ailleurs et pas
loin d'ici
les temps sont durs les temps sont durs
pour notre pays laissant les temps sont
durs pour les habitants notre pays parce
que nous sommes dans une situation où la
crise économique qui ne nous épargne pas
se double d'une crise économique mais
d'une crise sociale mais aussi et
surtout d'une forme de déprime
désespérance et les temps sont donc
encore plus difficile pour les
responsables politiques qui font l'objet
et parfois de leur faute d'une forme de
discrédit d'absence de confiance qui
fait qu'il est difficile de pouvoir
conduire comme l'a dit christiane tout à
l'heure des chantiers qui nécessitent
que l'on ait la confiance de ceux qui
nous ont élus à nos responsabilités
alors dans ces moments là il faut être
sans doute plus serein plus ferme plus
droit et osé défier les modes le buzz
légumes des choses tenir bon tenir bon
sur ses convictions tu as raison
philippe tenir bon et pas baisser la
tête
tenir bon et ne pas se taire ne pas se
taire parce que nous sommes dans un pays
la france qui a été capable de donner
beaucoup de ses voix à une candidate de
l'extrême droite
nous sommes dans un pays la france où
son discours a contaminé jusqu'à une
large part de celle qui a été et c'est
tout à son honneur
un rempart et une digue pendant
longtemps contre l'extrême droite je
veux parler de la droite dite
républicaine et nous sommes dans un pays
où ce discours a instigué les esprits et
où certains certaines sont aujourd'hui
plus soucieux de revanche de tension que
de construire ensemble l'avenir malgré
les difficultés
alors oui nous devons et je le dis avec
franchise et sans aucune volonté de
renvoyer la balle à quiconque c'est une
responsabilité collective nous ne
pouvons pas nous renvoyer la patate
chaude
oui il faut faire reculer le front
national mais aussi les idées du front
national
et pour ça et pour ça il faut assécher
le marais du désespoir qui envahi une
partie notre société pourquoi et comment
pourquoi parce que les solutions que
proposent les politiques on trouvait des
limites ses limites on les connaît c'est
celle d'un modèle économique d'un modèle
de développement qui était peut-être
possible et qui a été possible pendant
un peu plus d'un siècle mais qui n'est
plus possible tout simplement parce que
la terre notre
annette a des limites ce sont celles de
ses ressources naturelles et que nous
avons donc la responsabilité de proposer
un autre modèle eh oui de le proposer
dans les actes nous ne ferons pas seuls
il doit être portée au niveau européen
ce sera une année importante l'année
prochaine pour parler de ce projet
européen et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens ici qui se souviennent de
nombreux moments où quelqu'un à qui je
pense en ce début de campagne européenne
disait que quand il était né exactement
neuf mois après le débarquement des
américains
il avait dit à ses parents qu'un jour il
n'y aurait plus de frontière entre la
france et l'allemagne
oui là l'europe s'est construit sur un
rêve celui de la paix il s'est construit
dans les actes autour du charbon et de
l'acier
et puis ce rêve là s'est délité et il
faut avoir le courage de reconnaître
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe n'apparaît plus
pour l'essentiel de des populations
européennes que comme un gendarme froid
un gendarme sans doute extrêmement
sévère un gendarme brutale qui n'apporte
pas de solutions l'europe doit redevenir
un espace de conquête un espace d'avenir
c'est celui qui permet et qui permettra
en matière énergétique de pouvoir
engager la transition
oui nous devons travailler comme nous
l'avons fait c'était une autre époque
c'était l'aéronautique à constituer ce
qui serait un airbus des énergies
renouvelables nous pouvons atteindre la
souveraineté énergétique en europe
voilà le chantier qui est devant nous
redonner du sens à l'europe
redonner cette capacité à la fois de
protection et d'engagement dont nous
avons besoin
enlevez ce voile de déprime qui recouvre
les populations européennes et cette
crainte qui pèsent sur la génération qui
a moins de 30 ans mais nous devons aussi
travailler sur un modèle qui s'applique
chez nous et dès aujourd'hui et oui
c'est possible
ce modèle intense en emploi et si
d'aucuns ont été surpris de la signature
d'un texte mousquetaires enfin si j'ai
bien compris dans les mousquetaires
philippe met une chorus si je me trompe
les nanas il avait des bijoux où elle
faisait la lessive c'est ça hein enfin
je peux faire aussi un mais
plus sérieusement ce modèle intense en
emploi ce modèle dans un monde qui ne
court pas après une croissance du pib
artificielle qui apporte parfois plus de
dégâts que deux solutions ce modèle là
il est possible
il est possible dans le secteur agricole
il est possible par la rénovation
énergétique
il est possible en convertissant
l'industrie chimique voilà le modèle que
nous pouvons porter mais ce modèle là
passe par une politique et des choix
d'investissements ambitieux alors oui il
faut regarder ce que nous avons fait et
il ya en effet une très bonne décision
je vais pas reprendre ce qui a été dit
mais je voudrais là aussi faire un clin
d'oeil
parce qu'elle a fait à mes anciennes
fonctions à tous mes amis qui sont ici
qui m'ont mois après mois emmenés dans
des réunions publiques des
manifestations et conférences de presse
pour expliquer qu'il ne fallait pas de
construire de nouvelles lignes de tgv
je pense à l'endroit où nous nous
trouvons d'abord parce que nous n'avions
pas les moyens
ensuite parce que le réseau existant
était en péril et que c'est à celui ci
qu'il fallait consacrer les moyens et
bien la décision qui a été prise dans le
cadre du plan d'investissements d'avenir
c'est de privilégier le réseau
secondaire de remplacer les trains
existants et d'améliorer la sécurité de
ce réseau c'est pas une décision facile
mais c'est une décision non seulement
qui va dans le bon sens mais que les
écologistes attendait depuis des années
et des années et c'est ce chemin là
qu'il faut prendre le chemin
d'investissement d'investissement sobre
efficace et utile c'est ce choix là qui
doit refuser l'austérité refuser un
modèle court termiste qui ne proposent
comme solution que d saurait encore
davantage ceux qui le sont déjà
c'est ce modèle là qui doit accompagner
engagé permettre la transition
écologique mais je voudrais surtout dire
que nous sommes dans un moment où la
bagarre s'est crispé il se trouve que le
président du medef a ciblé ses
adversaires il est contre la fiscalité
écologique
il est pour les gaz de schiste et il est
pour le développement du nucléaire
on s'est senti visé je crois pas à tort
mais moi je voudrais répondre assez
simplement peut-être qu'il y a trente
ans ça aurait été possible
ya 30 ans quand on moquait les
écologistes qui expliquer les dangers
des particules fines et de la pollution
automobile ya 30 ans quand on riait au
nez de ceux qui disaient que ce bas coût
de l'électricité nucléaire fabuleux
franco français c'était un mensonge
d'état
un mensonge délibéré et que nous allions
payer cher aux écologistes qui disait il
ya trente ans que la biodiversité était
en péril et que si nous ne changeons pas
de modèle agricole nous risquerions
d'avoir des scandales sanitaires et
d'avoir des conséquences sur la qualité
de l'alimentation très fort on ne peut
pas dire aujourd'hui que les écologistes
ont moqué ya 30 ans avait tort il avait
raison il avait raison alors je vous le
dis et c'est comme ça que j'aborde l'em2
l'irresponsabilité a changé de camp ceux
qui veulent essayer de faire vivre à
tout coup et à tout prix les derniers
jus de la rente sur le capital naturel
c'est eux qui seront coupables de nos
difficultés
l'irresponsabilité a changé de camp
c'est à eux de rendre des comptes
aujourd'hui
alors ne soyons pas timides et ne soyons
pas naïfs
ce sera un combat difficile parce qu'il
nécessite
oui de prendre des décisions dont les
responsables politiques qui en ont la
charge ne verront pas la mise en oeuvre
ou les résultats il s'agit d'expliquer
aux habitants de notre pays que certains
virages que nous allons prendre et que
nous devons anticiper préparer rendre
collectifs sont l'intérêt et l'intérêt
absolue de leurs enfants et de leurs
petits enfants
il s'agit dans un monde bouffer par
l'ultra court terme de redonner une
perspective du temps long de l'an viii
et de la confiance
alors je le dis dans ce combat difficile
qui est un combat politique au sens
noble du terme celui de retrouver le
lien entre les responsables politiques
et la société
nous avons besoin de tout le monde et
nous ne pouvons pas tolérer la division
alors puisque tous les partenaires qui
sont ceux de la majorité ou à minima ce
qui ont permis et c'est très important
que nicolas sarkozy n'ait pas été réélu
président de la république et que ce
soit françois hollande qu'il le soit
cette responsabilité elle est collective
dans tous les moments de l'histoire où
une partie de la gauche à chercher dans
la gauche c'est plus farouche ennemi
c'est la droite c'est la réaction c'est
les conservateurs qui ont gagné à chaque
fois l'histoire est impitoyable
alors nous avons ce devoir ce devoir il
passe par le respect il passe par
l'écouté il passe par la capacité de
dialogue et moi je sais que les uns et
les autres ont raison que certaines
alertes sont justifiées que oui un
certain nombre de mesures de ce
gouvernement n'ont pas été comprises
mais d'autres ont été courageuses nous
allons aborder une deuxième rentrée des
classes qui se souvient que c'est cette
majorité qui pour des millions de
familles à augmenter de 25% l'allocation
de rentrée scolaire au moment où pour
certains c'est un moment où passante
dans les rayons des magasins
les mères et des pères de famille ont le
ventre noué de ne pas pouvoir assurer à
leurs enfants ce qui est le minimum
nécessaire c'est à dire de pouvoir aller
à l'école dans de bonnes conditions
alors moi je suis lucide et fier
lucide parce que nous ne pouvons pas
dire que tout se passe bien que tout est
simple
fier parce que nous avons la
responsabilité nous avons la chance la
chance que les électeurs nous est donnée
cette responsabilité de conduire le
changement et nous devons être à la
hauteur
nous devons être à la hauteur et c'est
nécessaire c'est nécessaire parce que au
delà des débats qui nous anime
entre nous il y a dans ce pays 66
millions d'habitants qui attendent des
réponses des perspectives un chemin une
envie et d'y croire et ça c'est la
responsabilité des politiques personne
personne n'est obligé prendre sa carte
dans un parti politique
personne n'est obligé de devenir élus
personne n'est contraint à être ministre
mais tous ceux qui font ce choix de
l'engagement le fonds en conscience et
cette conscience c'est d'être utile à
l'intérêt général
et c'est le moment tous et tout je crois
de s'en rappeler et puis je voudrais
dire aussi à tous ceux qui croient que
parfois il ya des permanences que non
les temps changent
les temps changent nous ne sommes plus
dans les années 80 enfin il ya un seul
point commun c'est que le patron des
patrons s'appelle toujours gattaz nous
ne sommes plus dans les années 80 où le
seul horizon c'était le fric et la
société de consommation
nous ne sommes plus dans les années 80
où l'on pensait avec beaucoup de sérieux
que les nuages radioactifs respecter la
frontière française
nous sommes en 2013 en 2013 ou la
catastrophe de fukushima n'en finit pas
nous sommes en 2013 ou la transition
écologique est possible si on la veut
vraiment nous sommes en 2013 est
aujourd'hui une ministre ça agit ça
ouvre sa gueule et ça ne démissionne pas
merci
merci beaucoup cécile duflot merci à
toutes et à tous d'avoir évidemment
participer à ce débat pour nous avoir
donné votre vision devant de moi je
voudrais dire quelques mots de
conclusion au nom d'europe écologie les
verts puisque nous avons voulu ce débat
sur laon 2 et sur le changement de cap
je voudrais commencer par toi christiane
pour l'intervention que tu as fait et
pour les mots tu as porté tu sais en
règle générale les écologistes il se
caractérise je parle de l'écologie
politique à travers un triptyque tu as
parlé du triptyque républicain de la
liberté de l'égalité de la fraternité
nous nous portons le triptyque de la
solidarité de la responsabilité et de
l'autonomie et je voudrais te dire parce
que parce que tu es ministres de ce
gouvernement que tu as parlé de la
question de la solidarité que tu as dit
que la france s'honorerait au nom des
raisons et de la lumière à accueillir
attendiez à tendre la main à tous ceux
qui souffrent dans le monde
eh bien j'aimerais te rappeler
christiane que pour la gauche et les
écologistes cette main tendue aux gens
qui souffrent aux gens qui sont obligés
de quitter leur pays de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée ou ailleurs plus loin
encore parce que nous les avons exploité
dans un modèle productiviste que nous
avons piller leurs richesses et que nous
les avons exploité en tant qu'être
humain ces gens là ils doivent être
accueillis par la france
non par des lois qui émane du ministre
de l'intérieur
mais par des lois qui émanerait du
ministre de la justice et de la
solidarité nationale
la gauche ne peut pas laisser et les
écologistes n'ont plus le ministère de
l'intérieur géré
la solidarité avec les peuples en
souffrance ça ça serait l'honneur
l'honneur de cette france l'honneur des
lumières l'honneur de la raison et je
rappelle à cet égard et je le dis car
c'était un engagement du président de la
république moi je n'ai pas oublié après
une intervention sur les roms d'un
certain nombre de ministres dont
évidemment cécile duflot qu'il y avait
eu une directive du premier ministre
pour dire maintenant la question des
flux migratoires et des solidarités
doivent être gérés par tous les
ministères concernés et pas uniquement
par le ministère de l'intérieur
eh bien il faut continuer à le faire car
il n'ya pas d'accueil pour les gens si
on n'est pas en capacité de leur donner
des logements décents de leur donner les
droits l'éducation
évidemment le droit à vivre en famille
grâce au regroupement familial partout
maintenant voilà qu'elle serait
l'honneur de la france
je le dis également je le dis également
au nom du mouvement écologiste
pour nous la solidarité on a parlé tout
à l'heure des retraites et on va parler
bientôt du chômage là la grande question
de la rentrée la question que nous
aurons à traiter au delà de la question
de la retraite c'est celle de
l'assurance chômage
et bien je vous le dis je le dis au
ministre mais je le dis je le rappelle
au nom des écologistes il n'y aura pas
de solution sur la question du chômage
sur la question des retraites si on ne
prend pas à bras le corps la question du
partage du travail
la question du travail et de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
la question de la formation des jeunes
la question de la formation des seniors
et le fait que les solidarité entre les
générations se met en place
c'est ça les solidarités du 21e siècle
ça n'est pas simplement de dire oui nous
allons trouver les financements pour ne
pas porter atteinte à la pénurie
pérennité des caisses de retraite il y à
un chômage endémique dans ce pays que ce
soit chez les jeunes que ce soit chez
les seniors qui fait que nous ne pouvons
pas traiter cette question comme elle
était traitée par le passé et ça m'amène
à passer à la deuxième partie du
triptyque la responsabilité notre
responsabilité d'écologie la
responsabilité de la gauche et des
écologistes en arrivant au pouvoir
maintenant c'est de dire la vérité aux
gens ça n'est pas de leur mentir ou
d'essayer de leur faire croire que je ne
sais que telle croissance où kate elle
relance va leur permettre de revenir au
plein emploi
ça n'est pas vrai ça n'existe pas nous
devons trouver
nous devons trouver les solutions d'une
nouvelle prospérité d'un nouveau vivre
mieux sans attendre le retour
hypothétique de la croissance
nous n'avons pas le droit de faire
croire aux gens que l'énergie va baisser
demain et que les énergies fossiles vont
revenir non ça ne reviendra pas les
matières premières sont en train de
s'épuiser les ressources aussi et nous
ne pouvons pas continuer sur ce schéma
là donc ayez ayez le courage parce que
c'est une question de responsabilité de
dire avec les écologistes que oui
philippe il faut fermer fessenheim mais
si je ferme fessenheim et que j'ouvre
flamanville
je n'ai rien changé aux modèles rien de
rien
nous devons le dire et nous le dirons la
transition énergétique
la responsabilité qui est la nôtre ça
n'est pas de faire croire aux gens qu'en
2025 on aura réduit la part du nucléaire
dans ce pays
si on n'est pas en capacité de
développer une industrie du renouvelable
et ça ça se financent et ça ne se
financent pas en 2024 pour 2025
ça se finance en 2013 maintenant dans la
loi de finances qui va arriver et on va
arrêter de financer la recherche
nucléaire
on va mettre l'argent sur la recherche
pour les renouvelables
c'est ça la responsabilité qui est la
nôtre donc tu as dit tu as dit
effectivement que on avait la volonté
d'associer la question du diesel qui est
un problème de santé publique avec la
question de l'industrie je le dis devant
nos partenaires du parti communiste
parce que je les dis dans un débat aussi
avec la cgt
cfdt il faut arrêter d'opposer
l'écologie à l'emploi et à l'industrie
c'est un 7-1 une vision du monde
je ne vous interpelle pas sur le fait
que vous ne le pensiez pas jeudi qu' il
faut maintenant maintenant que nous
crions les convergences dans la société
puisque on a parlé de convaincre la
société nous n'y arriverons pas les uns
sans les autres
quand la cgt à flamme à âge allez dire à
flamanville a mais bon c'est pas très
loin cela étant c'est en normandie
quand la cgt est en train de développer
un projet d'économie circulaire proche
de ce que porte à l'institut de ladite
économie notre ami françois michel
lambert elle est en train d'inventer le
nouveau monde
elle est en train de savoir que des
automobiles il n'arrive plus à en
construire et finalement c'est ce modèle
de transport qui est derrière nous mais
elle elle veut recycler les véhicules
qu'elle a construit il y à une directive
européenne qui dit que les véhicules ses
85 % de recyclables et on recycle rien
ou quasiment
et bien ce monde là là aussi il faut en
changer et on ne le changera pas contre
la cgt on ne la changera pas contre les
industriels et je dirais même contre la
volonté nous le ferons du medef on le
fera avec et ce monde là c'est
effectivement le monde du 21e siècle et
nous avons la responsabilité de le
porter ensemble car sans cela nous ne
créerons pas les emplois de demain
nous ne serons pas en capacité de mettre
en place les vrais métiers d'avenir les
emplois d'avenir
ce que nous devons à nos enfants est ce
que nous devons à tous ceux qui sont au
chômage alors la responsabilité
c'est effectivement de dire la vérité
mais la responsabilité je vous le dis en
tant que parlementaire et en tant que
ministre
s'il vous plaît c'est de faire ce que
l'on a dit que l'on ferait que l'on
sorte que l'on sorte des annonces que
l'on sorte des discours pour maintenant
mettre en place les actes
je t'assure philippe l'année dernière tu
étais là pour entendre le discours sur
la conférence environ
le mental nous avons tous soutenu ce
discours sur la conférence
environnementale mais la nécessité
maintenant qui est celle de tous les
écologistes
on a été à vos côtés on a porté avec
vous cette volonté de transformer mais
je t'en supplie ne nous fait pas ne nous
faites pas ce que le grenelle avait fait
c'est d'abandonner en cours d'euro des
engagements qui ont été souscrits devant
les françaises et les français à aller
au bout ayez le courage nous sommes là
avec vous et nous le ferons alors et
j'ai terminé parce que je voudrais
vraiment pas aller trop loin
l'autonomie j'ai dit oh non je suis pas
allée très loin je peux faire bien pire
oui oui je t'assure l'autonomie pour
nous écologistes
ça n'est pas de ne pas être solidaire
des majorités dans lesquelles nous
travaillons ça n'est pas de refuser la
tâche qui est d'être devant nous c'est
de continuer à le faire
en portant les valeurs de l'écologie
politique nous ne céderons jamais jamais
à la tentation de renoncer à ce que nous
sommes de renoncer à nos convictions et
de porter seul s'il le faut dans la
société et dans cette majorité
notre vision du monde nous nous ne
paierons jamais tout simplement parce
qu'il est de notre responsabilité de
dire comme l'a dit geneviève tout à
l'heure que les crises sont devant nous
mais ce que nous rappellerons et nous
continuerons à le dire haut et fort
c'est que si les cris sont devant nous
les solutions ne sont pas derrière nous
ce ne sont pas celles du passé que nous
devons mettre en oeuvre ce sont les
échos les solutions de maintenant celle
d'un nouveau modèle celui que porte
l'écologie politique vous voulez le
porter avec nous chiche
faisons le nous on sera à vos côtés